[音楽]
まずこの写真を見ていただきたいんですけどね
この画像に覚えありますでしょうか
これはこの8月
日本の若い女性が総理に
行かれてその時に
a
韓国のはまあ多分若い男性でしょうね2
まあいわゆるナンパをされてそのナンパをされたのを無視して歩いていたら
青鹿毛られた髪の毛をし引っ張られて引きずり倒されるみたいなですね暴行を受けた
って言うんですね
お話ですこれはあの実は本物はマホニーソっていうかですね
動画だったので
テレビん同じ6テレビの一番たくさんですねのバラエティーとニュースバラエティ中で
も報道されて
でまぁ youtube なんかもたくさんあっているところですながら見た方多いん
じゃないでしょうか
で
実はこの事件が起きた日の夜
僕は
ソウルの空港に到着したんです
それは日本と韓国との間で学会が国際学会がありまして私はそれに出席する必要があっ
たからも安い
で空港に降り立ってまあスマホのですね電業高を入れると
私のラインとか
メールとかに私の友人知人からたくさんですね
この時に韓国って大丈夫か
ねっ
それから
お前少なくとも日本語を話すなよとか
最悪なのはの生きて帰って来いよそう言うねあのお年のは僕がまだこれが起こったこと
わかってないので
一体何なんだろうと思ってですねはちょっと驚きながらもですね要するに
スマホを受けてしまってですね1回ホテルに着きました
いうことについてどうもこういうことが新しいたらちょっと調べたんですけどその日の
夜には韓国の学会が主催している信仰心会があったので私はそこはいかなければいけ
ない
で懇親会2分地図を片手にですねえ
ソウルの街をうろうろと歩いていたらですねまぁ案の定
道に迷ったんです
で私は道に迷うとあの基本的に人に聞くタイプの人間なので是非私は残念なことに
こりゃができませんだからまあ片言の英語でわかりそうな人っていうのをキョロキョロ
と探しながら歩いたんですがそしたらちょうど前からですね
お巡りさんがやってきたでっ夜回りさんだったらまあ英語としできるだろうし
道もよく知ってるだろうと思って
僕はですね片言の英語でですね
自分が液体レストランどこにありますかと聞いたんです
するとですねそのまわりさんは
日本の方ですか
日本語で聞いたんです
僕はドキッとしますねー
いやこれちょっと
もし何か難癖つけられて不当逮捕とかされたら韓国に知っている弁護士もいました
一瞬思ったんですでだから僕はの iphone チャイナって
八かなと思ったんですがさすがにここは腹を決めてですねそうです
日本語で
返上します
すると
そのおまわりさんはですねニコッとほほえむあれ
ようこそ監獄へ
って言って地上に丁寧にですね日本語で
僕が行こうと思っていたレストランを教えてくれます
つまり
ここで
起こったことはですね日本のメディアによる情報
ニュースを見ていた僕の友人たちは日本まあいわゆる反日ムードが非常に高まっている
ねっ
は大変な時に君が入ってるね行って心配してくれた大
ところは実際に韓国に行った私は思われさんとても親切にしてもらって
そして
全然半日フーズ案というのを感じなかったんですね
つまり大きなギャップがあったんです現実メディアが伝える連日
と
え本当の現実
でこのギャップはどうしてその生じたのかって言うとですね
まあこれをちょっとその
料理例えばなすお話をしたい
皆さんは
中華料理を好きだと思いますね日本人大好きな
料理ですベスト3とかに入るらしいんですけど
この中華料理屋さんに行くと
ある統計だとですね3人に2人は他のものはものが餃子なそうなんですよ
この餃子ってつまり中国の料理ですから餃子っていうのが中国のもちろんあるんです
けれども中国に行かれた方はわかると思いますが
中国で餃子って注文すると
焼いてないんですよ
茹でてあるゆでた餃子カベウマつまり日本で言うとこの水餃子というものが出てきます
基本的にはもう焼き餃子ってない店のほうが多い
ねっ
で
この餃子というものがですね要するに同じ名前で当然日本で中国でも餃子と言います
けれども同じ名前で
で同じ食材基本的は同じ食材を使っているんですけども
料理4やるまあ味付けが違う
なんでまあこういうことが起こるのかというとまあ言うまでもないことなんですけれど
も
もともと橋は中国ですから
それを日本に導入するときに日本のまあいわゆる
料理人の方が日本人の口に合うように調理をして味付けをしてですね
で提供しているわけです
で
実はこのことはニュースの世界でも全く同じことが起こります
つまりわれわれが普段中国の
いう中国で公共こういうことがあったとかですねそういった中国のニュースっていうの
を見たり聞いたり読んだりしているものというのは
実は日本のジャーナリスト記者の方がですね
日本いろんな素材があるんだからニュースの素材がある中で
これは日本人の口に合うだろう
と言って選んでしかもそれを日本我々日本人が面白い
わかりやすいようにありつけをしてですね
要するに皆さんのところに提供しているわけですから
我々が中国の情報集中国のニュースというものですね日本のメディアから入手している
on
というのは必ずしもですね中国の本場のつまり現地の中国のメディアが報じているもの
と同じとは限らないわけです
で
これが一体何が問題が起きるのか
これはこれこのここで何か問題が起きるのかというとですね
先ほどのちょっと餃子の例をですねとってお話をすると
例えばお互いの国の餃子所事情についてよく知らない全然知らないですね
日本人と中国人が餃子談義を始めると考えています
つまり
餃子っていうのは
どんなお酒に合うのか
どこのお店がの餃子が美味しいかとか
餃子の真髄とは何なと思うんですねまぁそんなあるようなお話なんですけれども
そうするとですね中国の方はややっぱり餃子にで可憐である
いやーやっぱりあの店の餃子焼き加減が上手だからあの店やっぱり最高であれ
はーって離さないわけです
でつまりこれはをな事業だというもの議論しようとしているんだけれどもお互いの国
ですね
その餃子というものが異なった味付けで伝わっているために議論の土台が
8時になっていない
っていうことになります
でこれは
今餃子の話だからですね笑い話で済むんですけれども
これが政治とか経済のニュースとなると
まあ
ちょっと大きな問題というか国際問題が起こることがあります
ん
で最近の例でですねえっとこういった問題が表に出たですね
話を一つしましょう
作業ちょっと言いましたけど今は戦後最悪の日韓関係と言われている状況の中で皆さん
はですねそのままに戦後最悪の一環環境
まあある意味演出したものの1つのニュースに
盗人猛々しい発言と覚えてますか
これは韓国の門大統領という方が発言したというふうに日本では伝えられたものなん
です
でこれいっちゃどういう文脈でこの発言を彼がなさったかというと日本が
韓国をですねいわゆる貿易上の手続きのですねまぁ優遇国から外すということを発表し
た
そろそろを受けてですね韓国のムン大統領が記者会見で盗人猛々しいというふうに発言
したというふうに日本では伝わりました
でこの発言を受けてですね日本の一部の政治家とか
まあいわゆる評論家とか
なんかニュースバラエティに出てくるようなゲストの人たちとかがの中からはですね
レーダー
スレだ
ん
大統領が口にするとは思えないような品の悪い言葉だね
韓国人の品格を疑うというようなですねリアクションが出たらを覚えておられる
ってところがですね実はこの問題というが本当に縁にされた言葉というのはここにあり
ますけれども
この直パン派じゃんっていうんだそうですねちょっとコリアができないで hati
あるんですけどもも a にょところがよく見ていただくと
これは漢字四字熟語ですよね
漢字四字熟語中のは日本でも同じですけれども
例えば驚天動地とかっていうのと同じように基本的にはちょっとまあインテリの人が
家にするような品のいい言葉なんです
韓国で光ってこれはよく使われている言葉だそうなんですけどもいずれにしても日本語
に
の盗人猛々しいとはずいぶんニュアンスの違う言葉です
で
これはですねー
しかもはさらにまあ悪いことにですね
韓国の今度は kbs なんかのメディアがですね
日本の
まあメディアとか一般の与論が韓国はれははが韓国大統領のですねこのチョッパー波山
という言葉が下品だとかなんとかっていうような報道をしているって事が来伝わっ
ちゃったんですよ
ではこれもちょっパン派山っていうのを盗人猛々しいと訳したという彼らは知らないん
ですよ
要するに餃子なら餃子と同じ餃子だと思っています
方かっチョッパんはちゃんどこある意味ん
要するにへ先ほど餃子の話と全く同じでもうちょっパン派じゃんって話がですね
日本刀かそのまあ日本での伝えられ方というのは結局日本風に味付けをされたわけです
当時の駄文メディアこれは私の知る限りではま西大手ではですね毎日新聞以外はみんな
この
これをウスと猛々しいと訳したんですけど nhk を不況池ですね
当時のやっぱり日韓のそれこそ戦後最悪のっていうのは状況に勘案
さらにま盗人猛々しいって訳したがわかりやすいした分受けるだろうというのまあ意味
でおそらくですねそういうふうに
な役をつけたと思うんですけれどもこれがですねやはり日本と韓国の間のお互いのです
ねまぁ国民感情というかですね
それをもうそこでたことは言うまでもないと思います
さて
実はこのように
外国のですね情報を自分の国正国民の口に合うような形で調理として
あ実を経営をしてもちろん洗濯もなんですけども育て伝えるというのは決してですね
日本だけの
まあ問題日本のジャーナリズムだけの問題ではありませんこれは実はもう世界中どこの
国でもですね基本的には同じようなことをやっています
で世界中の国で同じようなことをやっているということは世界中の国でそのさっき言っ
た日韓関係でショパン肌みたいなですね問題は起こりうるということを意味しています
ショコラないわゆる国際報道の世界ではもう長らくですねもう大きな問題提起されてい
たんですけれども
この問題をですねこう解決方法はないのか
っていうと実はですねこれは一つヒントがですねヨーロッパにあります
で
これはヨーロッパにですね私がまあ10年10年以上前にちょっとお邪魔した時に自分
で撮ってきた写真なんですけども
euronews というですねまあこれは放送局というかジャーナリズニュース専門
の放送局がありますもちろんインターネットでも
流していますので皆さんはフェスされればですね見ることができますがこのユーロ
ニューズというのはですね
フランスのリオンにありますがただし欧州中玉公共放送を中心とした
ジャーナリストを集めで公共放送からまあ基本的なお金は
集めてですね運営されているものです
でこのいろいろニューズの
特長の1つはですねヨーロッパの料理を
とぼけているということです
基本的にはだからドイツの放送局というのはドイツ風に味付けをしたフランスの話とか
イギリス話とかをしているわけですけれどもところが
このユーロニューズはですねヨーロッパ料理というものをつくってつまりヨーロッパの
味付けで欧州の視点から見た選択をして news の選択ですね
そしてそれをヨーロッパの国々にあまねくですねを伝えるということをやっています
そしてまあ今この写真が出ていますけれども
二つめの特徴にですねこのユーロニューズのすごいところは
現在
ヨーロッパの12の言語で放送してるんですよ
で今この写真というのは一つ一つがですねこれ言語別のジャーナリストが入るブースに
なっているんです
このこっち側に foma いわゆるプロジェクターとスクリーンがありまして例えば
ライブ中継なんかをですね放送するときにその同じ画面を見見ていて
見ながらですね要するに異なる言語でこう伝えている
ということは
そのユーロニューズを見ている方は自分が慣れ親しんだ自分の言語ですね
で同じヨーロッパ中の人が同じ情報
聞いたり見たり
読んだりすることができているということです
でそれはですね言うまでもないことです先ほどの餃子の話ではありませんがみんなの
共通理解がを可能になる
つまり同じニュースを消費しているわけです
そうするとこういったことがまあ当然のことながら欧州の中での国際理解を深め
そして現在のですねヨーロッパ統合に一躍買っていることはもう言うまでもありません
さていっ
ここで最後にですね
皆さんご提案があります
皆さんは同じ釜の飯を食った仲間という言葉をご存知でしょうか
つまり私が提案したいのは同じアジア料理という
アジアのニュースのことですが者の視点で選ばれたニュースのことですが
アジア料理というものをアジアの人たちみんながですね同じものを
食べる消費するということで
今よりももう少し仲良くなれるんじゃないでしょうか
で
これはえーっ
つまり
同じ
政治的な問題でもまあ経済的な問題でもなんでもいいんですけれどもそれを話し合う
ときの土壌としてですね
同じニュース同じ情報を基に議論をするということを意味しています
でぜひ皆さんに考えて頂きたいのはですねこれを先ほどニューロニューズに倣えば
できればですねー
日本には日本語で
韓国にはこりゃぼれ中国にはチャイにですね
いう形でですね要するに同じ情報を異なる言語で
つまりそれぞれの国の食べやすい形で提供することで皆が同じですね情報という土台に
もってアジアの問題を議論することができるんじゃないでしょうか
で最後にですねまぁこの中に今日は日本人の方がほとんどオーディエンスだと思います
けれどもアジアの方も見ていただくけると思っていますのでお話をしたいんですがね
これこれまで述べてきたように要するに自分の国へディアが伝える
外国のニュース
を
だけをですねまぁ信じてへ
それを毎日読んだり見たり聞いたりしているだけでは真の国際理解はできません
ぜひですねこのアジア共通のニュースの必要性というものをですね皆さんお考えになっ
ていただいてそれが必要だなと思ったらですね
それぞれの国の中で声を上げていただいてデーわかっ公共放送に働きかけるでもですね
まぁお金持ちの人に働きかけるでもなんでもいいんですけれどもそういう
形でですねこういった euronews のアジアバーみたいなものを作り作って皆
でですね
同じアジア料理を食べて
アジアの問題はですね議論できるような
場にしたいというそういう日が来ることを1日もですね早くことを私は祈っています
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]
[音楽]